i Botter hat einen Traum sie will
adlerjägerin
werden damit traut sich die 15-Jährige
in ein Feld das hier im wen der Mongolei
eigentlich Männersache ist das einzig
weibliche sind die adlerdamen sie sollen
aggressiver sein als die mennchen die
Jagd ist Familienerbe das Wissen wird
weitergegeben von Vater zu
[Musik]
ich habe meinem Vater den Traum
gestanden mit Adlern zu jagen erst war
er dagegen aber es ist doch nicht in
Stein gemeißelt dass das nur Männern
vorbehalten ist ja ich bin verliebt in
diese
Steinadler 70 Jahre lang war die
Adlerjagd verboten seit den 90ern seit
dem Übergang vom kommunistischen System
zur Demokratie gibt es sie wieder die
Tradition überlebte weil einige heimlich
weiter mit Adlern jagten vor allem
Nomaden wie albottas
Familie doch auch von ihren Verwandten
sind nicht alle begeistert von ibotteras
Begeisterung es ist falsch Mädchen als
adlerjägerinnen auszubilden soweit ich
weiß kannten unsere Vorfahren auch keine
adlerjägerinnen Mädchen und Frauen haben
andere Aufgaben zu erledigen sie sollen
stricken und nähen lernen wie sie die
Hausarbeit machen und solche
Dinge ihr Vater unterstützt sie
inzwischen die beiden trainieren für
einen
wettbewerbotta will beweisen dass auch
Frauen das können den Adler hat ihr
Vater als Küken aus dem Nest geholt und
[Musik]
aufgezogen noch trainiert meine Tochter
mit meinem Adler sie hätte ger ihren een
aber sie geht noch zur Schule und ich
zwei Vögel
kümmern sie sollen noch so lange üben
bis sie fit genug für die Jagd ist erst
dann bekommt sie ihr eigenes
junges die Schule kostet Botter viel
Zeit heute fährt ihr Vater sie mit dem
Pferd braucht sie sonst eine Stunde die
Mongolei ist viereinhalb mal so groß wie
Deutschland und der am dünnsten
besiedelte ST der Welt gerade mal gut 3
Millionen Menschen leben hier dr
[Musik]
Nomaden Botter geht gerne zum Unterricht
doch zwei Jungs aus ihrer Klasse ärgern
sie weil sie mit Adlern jagt sie SLE
lieber Mädchenarbeit machen wie sie es
nennen ich muss Ihnen nichts beweisen
denn ich habe diese Jungs schon beim Arm
drücken
[Musik]
geschlagen
mit ihrer Abneigung bestärken sie mich
sogar der Tag wird kommen an dem ich
Erfolg habe und dann werden sie es
bereuen dass sie uns Mädchen nicht
zugetraut haben das zu schaffen ich ma
was ich für richtig halte folge meinem
Herzen und Schere mich nicht darum was
andere
denken das Überleben ihrer Familie hängt
heute nicht mehr von der Jagd ab mit den
ADN jagen sie vor allem
Füchse als Belohnung bekommen die ein
Teil der
be der Rythmus der anderen Tiere
bestimmt das Leben von albotteras
Familie sie sind Selbstversorger Milch
und Fleisch kommen von den jackskühen
und Pferden Botter hilft überall
mit schon als Kind aber kümmerte sie
sich am liebsten um die Adler für die
Jagd braucht sie viel Kraft sie muss
einhändig Reiten mit dem 8 K Ihren Vogel
auf dem Arm es dauert Jahre alle
Techniken zu lernen und das Vertrauen
des Adlers zu
gewinnen heute machen sie die Pferde
fertig denn i Botter will an einem
Wettbewerb teilnehmen und sich mit den
besten Jägern der Region messen 130 km
entfernt der Weg dorthin ist schon die
erste
[Musik]
Prüfung zwei Tage zu pfert
von früh morgens bis zum Abend des
nächsten
Tages wat und ihre Freundin haben es
geschafft sie sind die einzigen Frauen
hier das Festival soll die alte
Tradition am Leben halten und Touristen
anlocken ich bin aufgeregt und ängstlich
heute fordern wir das Glück heraus ich
konnte fast die ganze Nacht nicht
schlafen weil ich mir vorgestellt habe
was alles passieren
könnte
in der ersten Runde müssen die Adler die
Stimme ihrer Jägerin erkennen und zu ihr
kommen ohne sich von den vielen
Geräuschen und dem Publikum ablenken zu
lassen die Zeit wird gestoppt und der
Reiter und seine traditionelle Tracht
bewertet von 52 Teilnehmern schaffen es
20 in die nächste Runde 18 Männer Ei
Botter und ihre
Freunden in der zweiten Runde müssen die
Adler auf einer Schleppe aus fuchf
landen albotas Freundin ist zuerst
[Musik]
dran doch ihr Adler hört die Kommandos
nicht tririftet ab und kehrt zum Berg
zurück sie ist
ausgeschiedben jetzt schauen alle auf
ibotter auch ihr Vater ist aufgeregt
doch ihr Adler kommt ibotta hat es
geschafft die ganze Anspannung fällt von
ihr ab
[Musik]
für eine Medaille reicht es heute zwar
nicht aber sie bekommt ein kleines
Preisgeld und noch wichtiger den Respekt
einiger Jäger auch wenn noch nicht alle
überzeugt
sind eines Tages werden sie ihre Meinung
ändern wenn ein Mädchen namens kosen
alot Wettbewerber gewinnt und als
weltbekannte adlerjägerin rum und Ehre
erlangt dann werde ich meine Verwandten
und Kritiker besuchen und sie fragen
warum sie nicht an mich geglaubt haben
und dachten Mädchen könnten keine guten
adlerjägerinnen
sein dann werden die adlerdamen nicht
mehr das einzigweibliche sein bei der
Jagd in der
[Musik]
Mongolei